acercamiento entre Estados Unidos y
Afganistán tras un intercambio de
prisioneros el líder tribal
hajibachirnos Ray volvió a kabul donde
lo recibieron con los brazos abiertos
tras décadas encerrado en Estados Unidos
todo a cambio de la liberación del
ingeniero estadounidense Marc frederich
retenido en Afganistán desde febrero de
2020 donde trabajaba en proyectos de
desarrollo
hoy a las 10 de la mañana el ciudadano
estadounidense Mark freerich que estaba
encarcelado en Afganistán ha sido
intercambiado tras una larga negociación
con los estadounidenses
había estado encarcelado desde 2005 por
supuesto contrabando de drogas y fue uno
de los últimos prisioneros afganos en la
prisión de alta seguridad de guantánamo
ahora tras su Liberación los talibanes
han interpretado esta negociación como
un posible acercamiento con Estados
Unidos
creo que si Dios quiere mi intercambio
crearía una ruta de paz entre Afganistán
y Estados Unidos
por su parte el gobierno dichoden ha
estado bajo la presión de los familiares
de las personas encarceladas en el
extranjero Y ha prometido intensificar
los esfuerzos por liberarlos
llevar la negociaciones que condujeron a
la libertad de Mark a una resolución
exitosa requirió decisiones difíciles
que no tomé a la ligera nuestra
prioridad ahora es asegurarnos de quemar
que reciba un regreso saludable y seguro
y se le dé el espacio y el tiempo que
necesita para volver a la sociedad a
pesar de haber estado recluido en
guantánamo las autoridades
estadounidenses aseguraron que la
liberación de norkshire no supone ningún
riesgo para los estadounidenses